cbs news senior white house and
political correspondent ed o'keefe
smiling away joining us from our
washington newsroom to talk with us
about
president biden's first hundred days in
office and the next ed good morning let
me start there with the infrastructure
plan we saw
amtrak joe yesterday touting the plan
what's his strategy in selling it
well you know the idea here is
essentially to boost public support for
the plan across the country they had a
similar issue
when the american rescue plan was passed
earlier this year where they found
there was broad public bipartisan
support across the country
just no bipartisan support on capitol
hill and that kind of gave democrats
permission to go ahead and do it on
their own without republicans
the thinking is if we can do that again
this time build public support and
either pressure republicans to sign on
or just determine that you know what we
can do it again by ourselves
and not necessarily suffer any
consequences and ed what about just the
styling and the packaging of this the
american rescue plan the american
jobs plan families plan i mean these are
relatively bland and mundane
descriptions for what are really
ambitious
proposals is that part of the strategy
to kind of
offset what might be republican
resistance to keep
what's what is transformative and make
it seem
pretty average yeah i think that is part
of it because you're going to spend
potentially
if everything he's proposed was passed
it'd be six trillion dollars in federal
spending we've never done
that at one time let alone in just a few
months
and so it's just an expansive idea or
set of ideas that he'd like to get done
republicans say
too expensive a lot of it is unnecessary
and we'd have to raise taxes why would
we want to do that but
if you look over and over again these
are plans that are considered popular
with the american public in part because
they feel
it's necessary to get out of this
pandemic and
in many respects because they feel
government wasn't necessarily doing
enough
to help the country over the last few
years the president is calling on
congress to pass
some form of police reform before
the one-year anniversary of the death of
george floyd
is that achievable well you know it's it
seems
that there's a good chance for this and
and there was a lot of encouragement
coming out of the president's speech
where he set that
ambitious short-term timeline i mean
memorial day now
only a month away at this point but the
day after there were conversations
between democrats and republicans who've
been working on this issue
quietly over the last several weeks
members of
george floyd's family family members of
other people who've died in police
involved shootings
on capitol hill meeting with democrats
and republicans then went to the white
house to talk about it
we'll know more about the potential
success of this in the next 10 days or
so
congress is out next week but when they
get back if the two sides can come
to leaders in the house and senate and
say we've got something here let's put
it on the floor and get a vote
that's a good encouraging sign of
bipartisan progress before we let you go
ed we just passed president biden's
first hundred days in office for the
next
100 how can we measure success or
failure
sure so jump ahead to saturday august
7th that'll be the 200th day in office
if any of these pla any of them doesn't
have to be exactly as written
but he can get most of what he's
proposing done in terms of
infrastructure and these other changes
and
child tax credits and universal
pre-kindergarten if that passes by
august
huge success not only for any president
but especially a democratic president to
be expanding the scope of government
after so many years of contracting it
that plus things like
police reform if that can happen i mean
any kind of modest bipartisan deal
would be a good sign for a city that
doesn't normally find a way to cooperate
yeah do you have a white board for the
second one
[Laughter]
we'll get it out of the closet and we'll
bring it along dust it up
very good mr o'keefe thank you very much
take care